I want to depress you just a bit
basically just to remind you how bad
things are and how little things have
actually changed since one of the
biggest crises of all time the second
biggest financial crisis really the one
that began in 2007 2008 and so I'm going
to just very quickly depress you of it
but I promise I will get to hopeful
positive things towards the end and we
have a huge amount of time so for big
fat problems the first I'll call the
financial problem the finance problem
and this is really what I mean by this
is the problem within the financial
sector and I'm going to be a bit
superficial here because I'm going to go
through lots of both economic thinking
and also economic history but what I
mean by this is a kind of
financialization of finance in other
words finance is financing finance and
what you see here in this curve this is
for the UK economy but the US economy
looks quite similar the degree to which
the financial sector has outpaced in its
size the rest of the economy so this is
looking at financial intermediation
which is basically banks but also whole
shadow banking system in all forms of
different types of financial
institutions growing much faster than
the rest of the economy and basically
this is because so much of the financial
sector has ended up just financing
finance insurance and real estate which
conveniently the acronym is higher and
so you know this often makes people
think oh god this is terrible we need to
kind of define analyze and kind of fuel
industry right so this is also why in
some countries industrial policy has
come back and the idea that we need to
kind of fuel the makers so these are the
takers and unfortunately this brings me
to the second problem which is that
industry has become very financialized
itself and by that I mean that
increasingly in many large companies and
this is data here for 466 of the S&P 500
companies the profits being earned or
not actually being reinvested back into
production back into the workforce
human capital and skill research and
development but used for exactly the
kind of things that Larry Fink was in
theory theory warning about so things
like share buybacks and so this data
here shows you that between 2008 so
after
financial crisis - 2017 these 466 big
companies spent over four trillion
dollars in share buybacks which was
equivalent to 53 percent of their
profits along with three point one
trillion as dividends and this would be
fine as long as they were all so you
know again reinvesting back in but that
yellow bit there which is the
reinvestment back into production
including skills has been falling and
you see this by the way also at the
macroeconomic level you might know that
GDP gross domestic product which is how
we measure output of the economy can be
broken down in different ways one of it
is on the spending of all the different
components of the economy so government
spending gee business spending I
consumption spending and that exports
and the iPart business investment has
been falling and this is not a
coincidence right this is precisely
because there hasn't been that
reinvestment I'm just going to say one
thing is I often forget to say it and
apologies if I often do these little
parentheses but this is a huge problem
and this basically is you know much more
of a problem than the so called the
robots are taking our jobs it's very
interesting if you look back at the
history of economic thought and I'll be
going through quite a bit of history in
just a minute David Ricardo one of the
first economists ever in 1821
wrote a book called principles of
political economy and chapter 31 don't
ask me how I remember these details I
can't remember what I did this morning
but chapter 31 of this book that he
wrote in 1821 called on machinery he
warned that this rise and machines were
displacing labor he was very worried
about the effect that the rise of the
machines today's robots would be having
on employment and wages but what we
ended up having for basically 200 years
and it kind of stopped around the 1980s
and onwards was that as long as profits
were being reinvested back into the
economy it kind of didn't matter
machines yes took jobs in one part of
the economy but as long as profits were
invested they reappeared in other places
and skills were also formed as an
endogenous function of that investment
process right skills don't only come
from workers sorry from government
training programs the
also come from if you're kind of taken
care of inside the company if you're
invested in and this is just really
important because there's so much talk
today about the future of work and the
robots what's going to happen without
actually putting these numbers in this
data at the center of the picture as
just as important to confront and this
is a corporate governance problem so
this was problem - sorry little
distraction there problem three is that
in a time where we would really need
serious ambitious policy as ambitious as
the kind of policies that got us the
welfare state or that got a man to the
moon and back again in one generation we
basically has states that have been
convinced by well unfortunately by
economists we unfortunately have lots of
influence that at best they can just
kind of tinker on the sidelines you
always have to first identify the market
failure and then you're allowed to do
something and this kind of leads to this
very patchy view of what policy is for
so in a moment where we're calling for
things like a green transition I'll get
to this in a second the fourth problem
is in fact climate change when we need
to in theory we're talking about it
approach the sustainable development
goals for real where we have a rise in
inequality at least relative inequality
in many countries and there's a talk
about reforming capitalism this idea
that you're just there patching up the
system and putting band-aids when it
goes wrong is simply not going to get us
what we need and it's not that these
market failures don't exist this is the
term that economists use market failures
and you always have to identify the
market failure before policy does
anything they do exist so let me just
give you some examples here when you
have positive externalities so goods
that create these really great spillover
is that it's hard to appropriate the
returns just for yourself you will have
under investment by the private sector
in that area so government comes in and
invests in things like basic research
the opposite when businesses are
producing too much of something that is
not good a negative externality then
government comes in and does something
like a carbon tax when you have
asymmetric information so cute little
companies don't get enough money because
the the banks don't actually know
anything about them because they don't
have enough history then you might need
government to come in and do SME lending
so again all these things you know
happen and this framework isn't
pletely useless but in a time where
there's at least talk about
rediscovering purpose in reforming
capitalism and rethinking the direction
not just the rate these tools are part
of the problem and forth as I just kind
of gave it away before the climate
problem this is kind of the problem if
we don't sort this everything else is
kind of irrelevant we've got twelve
years left the IPCC report if you
haven't read it read it
Greta young woman reminds us that our
house is literally on fire second time I
use the word fire interesting you can
use it both for climate change and the
financial sector it's probably not a
coincidence and you know and
unfortunately it's not just that there's
not enough spending on renewable energy
this also is data from the IPCC so
apparently we're only spending about 20%
of what we should be in terms of really
getting a renewable energy revolution
going but Green is not just about
renewable energy it's really about
transforming our economy's work so
getting some old manufacturing sectors
to reduce the material content and the
history of capitalism we've often
required real kind of bold demand side
policies not just that supply push and
we're not getting those